next we have Tristram Stuart the food
campaigner who is going to talk about
why do we pay for waste so thank you
good morning ladies and gentlemen
wouldn't honor to be here I'm going to
talk about how to take on what is one of
the biggest challenges in the global
food system and that is waste I will lay
out to start with the fact that my
ultimate goal is to tackle what I call
the production espera dine in the food
system and to do so I need to have a
strategy a strategy that works for a
general population and a strategy that
works for policy makers and a strategy
that works for corporations so the place
in which I start is what I could call
the Achilles heel the vulnerable very
easily expose Abul hypocracy within the
food system and that is the issue of
food waste what you can see here is a
photograph that I took on one of my
recent research investigations into the
supply chains of European supermarkets
this is around a thousand tons of
tangelos of beautiful citrus fruit it's
in Peru and all of these fruits are
being wasted because of minor cosmetic
imperfections if you're having
difficulty seeing what this guy is
pointing out on the skin of his tan
jello that's kind of the point there's a
very minor skin scar and as a result of
these completely irrelevant have no
impact whatsoever on taste or
nutritional value or longevity of the
fruit all of this fruit is being wasted
he tries to sell some of it locally but
the local demand for tangelos is not
sufficient to soak up the sheer quantity
of rejects from the export supply chains
that he's mainly growing for of course
this isn't a problem just in Peru we go
around the world exposing this problem
these are carrots grown in the UK most
of these are being rejected and either
being sent off to livestock field feed
or being dumped in fields to rot because
they don't fit into the packets or the
supermarkets they're too long so one of
our strategies is really to pick on some
of the most absurd examples of food
waste really as a way of prising open
the whole problem this is where we found
one of the those exact pinnacles that
articulates the absurdity of our whole
system I bring your attention to the
word Kenya on this packet of green beans
these are grown in Kenya and then
trimmed but the funny thing about the
way these beans have been trimmed is
it's not just at the kind of tip and
tail we all know you know we don't eat
the stalk a bit of the green bean right
but let's see a show of hands who eats
the wispy little tail at the end some
people do some people don't but you know
at least we can agree that if you're
going to trim it off you trim it off at
the end of the beam but these have been
trimmed off not at the end of the beam
but halfway through why because that
packet was exactly nine centimeters long
and the green beans didn't know they had
to be nine centimeters long so they grow
all sorts of lengths and these are the
green beans that have won the race
they're the straightest greenest most
beautiful beans and then right at the
end twenty percent at the bean are being
chopped off and all of that is total
wastage there's no local market in Kenya
for these green beans they call it
Muslim gourd it's white man's food why
should they eat it and they're not
interested and so it all goes to waste
and the other problem that these Kenyan
farmers that we speak to regularly
encounter is the problem of order
cancellations so there is a risk in the
market we can never exactly predict
demand how many green beans we're gonna
eat or indeed Kenyans can't predict
whether the Guatemalans will have a
bumper crop and therefore supermarkets
here in Europe or wanna buy their green
beans at a cheaper price and so what you
often find is ladies like this one
growing on an acre and a half Memo Kenya
will spend their year growing the crops
investing money in them going to debt
very often to buy the inputs to grow the
crops and then at the last minute the
order is canceled
and ironically these are March - and not
one of these Monte will actually be
mulched they will be wasted she's not
going to harvest any of it because the
order was canceled these ladies who work
for less than $2 a day are destroying an
entire crop of basil because an order
was cancelled and they explained to us
that on occasions like this they don't
get paid or they get paid half wages at
best they can't feed the kids they can't
send them to school now these are in the
supply chain of our supermarkets and we
are currently paying for it why not a
single person I believe in this room or
indeed in Europe thinks that what I've
just told you about is okay and yet it
goes on so our attempt is to galvanize
the public around this issue both to
reform the issue of food waste but also
to take on as I say the production is
paradigm and to recalibrate the general
trajectory of the food system the first
thing you've got to do is get your facts
straight which is why I wrote my book in
2009 on the issue of food waste and the
second is to make it very accessible to
a wide population and there is no better
way of making food issues more
accessible than through people's
stomachs getting them to eat it so we
started creating this format feeding the
5,000 feeding 5,000 people or more with
food that otherwise would have been
wasted in celebratory ways that get
people together around the simple
solution to food waste namely eating and
enjoying it together rather than
throwing it away we've held these events
in over 50 cities worldwide this is one
we did in in Nairobi and the other is to
make it fun so we take volunteers to
fields where crops are being wasted we
get harvest it and give it to charities
that feed hungry people this makes us
pretty much unassailable from the
corporations that we then take on in
quite aggressive and confrontational
ways because no one will stand up to a
lady like this when she's all she's
doing is harvesting crops that are being
wasted for no good reason
and putting it to its proper purpose we
galvanize public opinion to the extent
that they are willing to boycott or move
away from certain businesses that are in
this essence
acting against the values of their
customers and sure enough that's when
the corporation's jump into action
Tesco was the first to do this they
stopped trimming the beans this cut
waist by over 30% overnight translated
across the sector this could save 20
million dollars worth of beans just in
bean trimmings and that represents about
point zero four percent of the entire
Kenyan economy how do we turn what
really should make us angry into
something that can spark a food
revolution well this made me angry when
I first saw it in 2008 remember this is
the food crisis of 2008 when lots of
people going out without food and in
Britain
we're wasting bread like this these are
the crusts of sandwiches the loaves in
the factories they throw around 13,000
slices of fresh bread from this single
factory every day so the final bit of
our strategy is to make the solutions to
this problem fun and what a better way
to do that than get wasted on waste we
we need money as well we're a non-profit
and it costs money to go out to brew and
do investigations so at the moment we
rely entirely on donations
we can't take money from corporates for
obvious reasons so my latest idea is to
turn this waste bread that we collect
and turn it into craft beer the
first-ever bottle is being tasted there
on Jamie Oliver's television program and
I was nerve-racking he really liked it
thankfully and what better way to fund
and generate a message to put a message
in a bottle and to say really the
solution to this problem the solution to
the production is system that as johan
rocks tom has just eloquently pointed
out the production is system that says
we need to double food production by
2030 is the one that not only is
factually incorrect because we already
grow enough food for 12 billion people
but it is the single biggest threat to
long-term global food security because
it's undermining the environments or
viability of our food system
so we've got to take that on we've got
to make it easy we're gonna make it fun
we're gonna make it delicious and
frankly we've got to have a better party
than the corporations that are currently
responsible for a food system that is
destroying public health and destroying
the planet and it's by coming together
with well the word companion really says
it all
companion literally means somebody you
eat bread with commas with and Pammy's
bread and through companionship by
gathering together as I hope we all have
today around common values sharing food
and having fun that's how we can flip
what is currently an ecocidal system
into as Johan said the biggest tool to
combat climate change and environmental
degradation thank you very much
[Applause]